okay uh
so you understand
your training model is always
uh following the only one there is
you're going to utilize stress
to generate an adaptation
the potential for that adaptation is
always within you
it's not something separate from you
okay
um
but it is something that you have
you do not have access to okay then you
have your training equations right so uh
the more stressful the cultivation field
is
the more needed the adaptation is
the more needed the adaptation the less
likely you are to cultivate it so
there's this balance that you have to do
okay
um
but
it doesn't change just because we're
working at the physical component or at
the energetic component
so we're going to look we're going to
utilize this training model this
cultivation model
energetically all right
so when we talk about the energetic
component we have to remember that
aikido's
uh epistemology is concentric and so the
to get you in the ballpark you want to
remember uh so Above So Below
so out so without So within
okay so outside so inside
so you can look for example at the
energetic component externally in terms
of Yin and Yang so remember what we're
trying to do is two things the lower
level thing or the entry level thing is
harmonizing and Young
and then the higher level thing is to
reconcile Union where they cease to
exist okay
so if we why we need to harmonize yin
and yang because if you don't harmonize
yin and yang you can't lead to a
Reconciliation of Yin and Yang okay if
you if you want you could understand the
ultimate harmonization that yin and yang
is a Reconciliation of Yin and Yang okay
so a contradicting yin and yang will
never lead to a reconciling of Yin and
Young so if we look at this externally
for example
um
he stands up and will work from the
clinch so you more understand it than if
we put it in keyhon because you have all
kinds of magical powers in Keyhole okay
which are not real so if we're in the
clinch and we're shoving at each other
do you see
this I have young energy and he has
young energy so here it kind of looks
like it'll work
because we're in that stalemate you see
so marshally but
energetically it's a young young Clash
okay and when you have a young young
Clash because yin and yang is relative
Whoever has more yawn is gonna make the
other one yet do you understand that so
if you come out
and uh we we push into each other you
see you push into me and I can you don't
have enough young energy
to overcome me you automatically by
default become yeah okay
so
what we do in an external harmonization
of Yin and Yang as he pushes at me
I'm not going to just let him out young
me
I'll harmonize with him and he pushes at
me in our mood
every as soon as he pushes on me I move
so he pushes I move
and that young now I can utilize you see
so if you look at what I did
in the clinch
I have a demonagon
right here Houston it's right there
so as he goes
Young
I yield
you see start the turn and then redirect
his young energy into the throne okay
so it's not it's not he pushes I push
her on him and then I decide to go
it's right when he pushes
foreign
okay
let's try that external harmonization of
matching Yin
to his yaw okay let's try it
okay
uh you might have seen the other posts
on Google Sen
okay so gono said is the timing but
people incorrectly identify it as
I wait until after his attack
to do my defense
okay
that's not it
I
go after his initiative
which is different the attack is the end
of his initiative okay so for example if
I'm here
and he braces on me do you see in the
Yong Yong Clash
come back
go a little slower so I can talk so
we're pushing into each other
and that's going to allow me to pop this
up and hit with my show my shoulder do
you see
where was my initiative
if you pay attention
it's right here
it's over now
the attack is the end of my initiative
what you see as the technique my my
initiatives started here
you understand
yeah okay so
regarding go no Sen energetically
it's when he pushes into me that I
disappear
I matched into Young
do you understand it's not
he gets down goes slow he pops
and he hits me it's too late now it's
too late I'm not going to get the
guillotine I'm not gonna help him in the
back he's compromising my balance you
see this is not good no Sen
this is just
losing okay do you got it so as he tried
as he's trying that that's where I go
into the end okay
so he's trying that and I go into the
end if you pay attention
it's really at the origin of this
his what I feel
if I wait to see it
his initiative has already manifested
okay so it's when I feel it there he
goes
it's really at the level of intention
it might look to you like I moved first
but he knows he was coming in do you see
and that is golden I moved after his
initiative
and it made it easy when I went external
yin to his yaw okay what you're gonna
find
is I'm late I'm late I'm late okay let's
try
thank you
[Music]
so there's the there was the young young
Clash did you see
[Music]
so you can see you're late
and you see what happens okay so again
in la la land of most Aikido Dojo
he would never go so far
it would not be enough stress
and the required adaptation to feel the
initiative
when it manifests
do you see not at its conclusion like
the end of my show manucci it's here
here at the level of intention the
initiative is started if you wait past
that you're too deep in the water you're
just gonna get nailed okay you got you
got that you won't find your solution
okay so uh he's doing he's doing show
minuti's in my head
right and as long as I know what he's
trying to do
then it's possible to go
do you see
but when I don't know what he's going to
do
you have to respond
to that true initiative not the final
manifestation so he goes and you're
already way out of the way it already
happened
okay if we change the the attacks for
example and we're sparring if he stays
still and I already got the angle do you
see this is already the initiative
he doesn't know what's coming in yet do
you got it so I he can't game the system
of giving up his flank here right
because it comes with all kinds of fakes
and faints
[Music]
he thought hi I went low okay
so instead if we're we're here we're
sparring I'd move on the true initiative
which is the start of his setting up of
of his attack I wouldn't ever wait here
he gets whatever position he wants and
then I expect to get out of the way of
this thing that's not going to happen
I respond to his true initiative at the
level of intention you see that's what
we're trying to do
so here in this back to our annotation
model
if I can't feel
his initiative
then I'm going to lose okay so we
increase the stress
to reveal that lack of adaptation okay
we can do this and to me that's an
energetic
adaptation to feel someone's intention
is it energetic
adaptation it you can't see it you see
it's not a physical thing
it's an energetic thing I can feel it
okay
so another way to increase the stress
for the energetic adaptation and to tell
whether the adaptation is present or not
is the following so uh we'll do we'll do
this technique okay
um let's peel this off peel this off
come under come around
peel it off boom under around
okay let's get in the ballpark okay so I
was using I thought in the last example
it's more more overtly externally a
Reconciliation of Yin and Yang do you
see and then to understand that that
reconciliation in gonosen has to happen
way earlier than we might think okay
but in the technique if you paid
attention you would you would know there
was a lot of internal reconciliation
that was happening
here in this technique I'm going to make
it such that it's going to be more
revealing of the external reconciliation
that's happening okay so uh but we do
have one
one kind of
um more overtly or easily more easily to
see on video an external reconciliation
okay so I can't out young that arm on
him I can't make this thing come off of
my neck okay
so she has her neck hold you see and I
can barely get that off but I was able
to get it off so that might be my
technique you see and I come around but
again you try that on Taylor's
you with your left hand try to clear
your neck hole
not gonna happen it's never going to
happen because that's a young young
Clash but he has Superior yawn you will
be the losing the loser on that okay
so what what I'm doing on the first one
he holds really tight I feed outside all
of this this has not being utilized it's
just in an IP adhesion which I'll
demonstrate later and I go around these
fingers
you see and the hand falls
I'm not shoving the hand down
I go around he's got it really tight
there's no way I could get that off so I
go around the fingers and the hand falls
and I connect to the hand okay so that's
where I see some of you are losing the
hand
okay
but
let's pay attention to you
you heal it and I will try to
demonstrate what's going on okay by
exaggerating the stressor
so
here
this is me externally pushing into him
what I'm doing here is his young energy
I'm grounding it and I'm actually in his
center now
so the same movement for example let's
say uh
you you uh
try to move your hand like you're going
to uh maybe you need to come around
like he's uh going to punch me go ahead
okay did you see that step Pizza okay
so I have his Center internally
and just by the simple change of his
geometry
he he lost his balance and he had to put
his base of support back under him did
you feel that okay it's not he goes to
move his arm and then I moved him
so you're watching the same thing maybe
you look for me I don't move he moved
his arm and it took him off balance okay
for you as I'm training you I'd like for
you to feel
that do you feel that okay so he goes to
move his arm and he has to step to
regain the balance okay that means he's
actually in a state of kazushi
internally do you see he's off balance
in the sense that he does not have
control of his balance I have control of
his balance which I did internally by
harmonizing Yin and y'all okay so uh
another one is uh let's say he tries to
pull back out so he tries to pull back
out okay so same thing he goes to pull
back out and same thing his balance gets
lost okay it's not that he goes back out
and I try to shove him down
I have his Center already he goes back
out he just makes his balance go you see
so
likewise uh that is my opening because
he's in kazushi okay so we'll slowly do
the first one I'm gonna wait till wait
till you feel and once you feel I don't
have you you see and then once you feel
that you feel that okay slowly move your
arm out
boom there's the groin you see here's
his balance here's the throw
foreign
[Music]
so what I'm doing
for the stress is don't move Dave don't
move have a center
he moves boom makes his balance go off
and then you have this rubber okay what
you'll find
if you don't have your Center
if he doesn't have my sinner don't try
to connect to it and I could just move
freely without losing my balance okay
so let's try that one
okay so we're we already know from God
no sen that the initiative already
happened right and so the idea that
you're actually going to move
when you feel or see my arm coming
that's not going to happen Okay so as
we're here and uh she's trying the
technique don't let me punch you you see
imagine I have a knife
she can never move fast enough do you
understand so this is where the internal
aspects are very martial because I
already have him
internally we know externally but I
already have him in kazushi internally
and as he moves I still had him it took
him off balance and so as he goes to
strike I'm already knee kicking him from
him being in kazushi the idea that I'll
be able to move it's not going to work
okay
same thing goes
we can add the stressor
of I have less Bass
do you see internally his energy needs
to come inside me
it's young energy I bounce it off the
ground it comes back up as Yin energy it
generates my Tom den and I use that Tom
Dan to do whatever I want to do
martially okay so here I have
no base I'm on my toes
you do not need anything but a pinpoint
to Bounce It Off the Earth so you don't
need
the bracing angle do you see
you can be here okay
and so he's driving now and I don't want
to go like this
he's driving
and we're just here he's pushing
you think you feel left he's driving
he's driving he's driving he's driving
he's driving
if I let it go
he'll push me over externally okay so
increase the stress by decreasing my
biomechanics he's trying to push and I
just brown brown brown brown
whoa keep your balance ground ground
break it he's gonna ride with it okay
try it go
you want to be on your toes
thank you
on your toes
without leaning
hey
so what you what you're seeing
internally is not not necessarily A
harmonization of Yin and Yang but a
Reconciliation of Gideon young okay so
that's why you see no movement in my
body and it generates a a an outcome on
him physically so for example in that
first drill when when I have his Center
and he goes to move it starts to take
him off balance okay
and I didn't have to move
all right so same way here as I come
back
and I am I am stuck on him as he stuck
on me right so last time I used it
passively with gonosen as he went to
punch that's what brought him off
balancing into the opening but you can
do it with the initiative timing okay so
as soon as I feel him press boom that
gives me that connection there and you
could use the same connection internally
to move his whole body right
without doing it externally okay without
having to move around just let it go and
you're carrying them throughout the
whole technique that way okay let's try
that one
so likewise in the technique that I'm
doing once once I peel her stuff
you see so I could peel
and not leave this balance there
I can move his balance as I move his
whole body around you see
and that's where I could do my peel
and we're stuck
so here I won't move
I'm not grabbing tight
but if he pulls and I'm external I'll
have to pull back on him if I'm internal
then this won't
pull me this pulls him
do you get that so I'm just stuck here
stuck here stuck here
all that gets internalized and without
moving it moves him as he resists it
okay I'm not cranking on it you feel how
relaxed my hand is okay so same thing so
he can't pull his arm away
he'll lose his balance and I'm stuck to
him but you don't see me
bracing
for the pull
you see that that'll have me pull
so as I come off oh we're in the ground
we're in the ground now and that moves
him so as I move it moves in
as he moves it moves in
okay without me shifting
embracing against the pulling energy so
we're increasing the stress right
because ideally martially if you pulled
my arm I should go in with him do you
see but energetically I can increase the
stress and I'm neutralizing it
internally okay try it
so both right she got out and you tugged
on her and it brought your base off
good same thing do you see that and
that's what will happen we'll lose our
base and we'll lose our connection right
good
will it increase again the stressor on
the udemy okay
so as I I have I have them in kazushi
right now internally I peel off here
we're stuck in an adhesion and I come
around okay so same thing if you look at
this arm trap it it is externally not
much of a trap you see that but this was
even less of a trap but because of that
Ike adhesion he's stuck you see so it
would be the same thing see as he tries
to pull it takes him off down but it's
not that I'm pulling on him I just
internalizing his energy okay so now
what we're going to do is we know we
have to ID me behind him right okay so
my weight my ground Vector is going to
change it's going to change onto this
foot over here okay and we'll exaggerate
his pushing externally I would yield
here right but for uh cultivation
reasons and observational reasons uh you
can see I don't have a basis of sport
you see there's no base spot there okay
it's all grounding no different than
when I was on my toes it's all going
down you feel that okay so same thing I
will exaggerate as I come on one foot
he's he's pushing
go back
as I come on one foot I'll exaggerate it
doesn't matter that it's one foot he
still can't push
you still can't push me over okay and
that whole thing moves into his body
okay so I'll do it again
whoa you could test here hey can you
pull what happens to him right you come
in here same thing he goes to pull what
happens to him I can exaggerate the
ground Vector over here he's pushing
with no base of support and I can
exaggerate the ground vector by
compromising my base entirely now we're
still stuck
that still adhesion is still there so
when I move I move to take him into the
kazushi pattern do you see it you see
what happened to his body okay it's not
that he's there then I go here and then
take him
he's pushing on me as I come around push
hard as I come around I use the adhesion
to take him into the kazushi powder
okay
try it
foreign
yeah there do you see
so that was the external
base
and so she's able to manipulate it
because she has the mechanical advantage
no base of support back there right
continue we'll let you passed it
and then you keep driving vouching and
you'll see you'll never get that foot in
edemy
yes do you see
driving into that bad biomechanics
yes there you go do you see
so there we muscled her do you see do
you get that
so all
all stressors increase in stress you see
it's such a level of stress that for
your levels it the adaptation is so
needed you're not going to cultivate it
there do you see that but it does show
that you can test for the adaptation you
see as you increase the stress or at
least the quality of the adaptation okay
but I would also put in there the
presence of any of it okay you can do
that
um I also think though that once you
have the skill you can observe what
someone's doing once once you know
how to do this energetically you can
watch someone else even on video and go
I know what's going on okay but when we
don't have this skill we only look at it
through these external eyes and maybe in
aikido's uh realm also these non-martial
delusional eyes such as what is go no
sen and things like that okay but if you
watch if you watch now for the technique
that we're doing I mean he could he can
feel where it's soft right and uh still
doing what I'm doing do you see that so
what you'll find as you do it is you'll
get pushed back because you're in train
on somebody who's pushing on you if you
see that but I'm doing internally it's a
yin yang reconciliation you get that as
his young energy is coming into my body
I do not have to externally move out of
the way so I can actually go forward as
he's coming forward do you see that and
I'll get the same result without
actually touching his hip like in the
first technique he will come up off the
ground and he will fall into the same
technique in very much the same exact
position pattern as the first technique
did you guys see that okay give it a
shot